la bannière étoilée qui disparaît les
emblèmes des états unis démonter la
prise de possession du désormais ex
consulat américain de chengdu par pékin
symbolise le dernier acte des tensions
sino-américaines source de cette mesure
de rétorsion la fermeture du consulat de
chine à houston vendredi
washington accuse la mission
diplomatique d'être une plaque tournante
de l'espionnage chinois
objectif selon la maison blanche
protéger la propriété intellectuelle et
les informations privées des américains
le président trump a dit ça suffit nous
n'allons pas permettre que cela se
produise à nouveau
vous avez vu les remarques du conseiller
à la sécurité nationale o brien
directeur du fbi à ivry du procureur
général bart nous avons défini des
attentes claires quant à la manière dont
le parti communiste chinois devrait se
comporter et lorsqu'ils ne le fera pas
que nous adopterons des mesures pour
protéger le peuple américain
notre sécurité notre sécurité nationale
et aussi notre économie et nos emplois
ce sont les mesures que vous voyez le
président preuve adopté et nous
continuerons à le faire
la réponse chinoise ne s'est donc pas
fait attendre et le message de pékin se
veut très clair tout mon soutien la
situation actuelle entre la chine et les
états unis n'est pas ce que souhaite la
chine les etats unis sont responsables
de tout cela encore une fois nous
demandons aux états unis de revenir
immédiatement sur leurs mauvaises
décisions et de créer les conditions
nécessaires pour remettre les relations
bilatérales sur de bons rails des
relations extrêmement dégradée et ce
depuis plusieurs mois ambitions
chinoises en mer de chine
la question des ouigours accusations
américaines concernant la gestion du
coronavirus par la chine
sans oublier la bataille entre les deux
pays concernant la 5g ou encore la
multiplication des sanctions économiques
américaines
les motifs de conflits se multiplient
entre les deux superpuissances une
montée en tension continue qui ne semble
pas prêt de s'apaiser